hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the new macbook not macbook pro not
macbook air just the new macbook and it
is insanely thin so like literally too
thin for normal batteries too thin for
any ports too thin for a normal track
pad even too thin for a backlight for
the apple logo i took a closer look at
this freakishly thin new laptop today
and these are my impressions so right
off the bat it's the thinnest and
lightest laptop i've ever seen weighs in
at two pounds which is actually a full
pound lighter than the 13 inch macbook
air and yeah it's just 13 millimeters
thin at its thickest point which is
again ridiculous you pick it up and you
wave it around and it's kind of hard to
believe there's an entire machine in
there now you can't go this thin in a
laptop without making some sacrifices
and apple has kind of tried to turn
these sacrifices into features at least
for some of them so first of all it's
too thin for a normal rectangular
battery cells so they've used contoured
battery cells which are essentially
stacked sheets of battery to fill out
the space that makes sense
next it's too thin for the backlit apple
logo that you see in the rest of apple's
laptops so you get a reflective one with
no backlight that we already have on you
know the iphones and the ipads already
so kind of a bummer for some people but
that also makes sense now this macbook
is also too thin for any sort of depth
in the keyboard so apple keyboards i
mean they didn't really have much travel
to begin with but this new macbook
keyboard has a new double-sided key
switch called butterfly switches which
are supposed to help with the typing
experience and make keystrokes feel more
even when pressing on the edges of the
keys i didn't notice much of a
difference in my brief use but that's
something i'll have to use more but
either way you look at it these are
really thin keys with very low travel so
this macbook is also too thin for ports
seriously it's rocking only one a single
usb c port on one side and an audio jack
on the other so through this usbc port
you do both power and all your data so
charging and if you want to do both at
the same time you'll have to use some
sort of an adapter in fact you'll
probably need multiple adapters there's
no way around this one this is the
biggest inconvenience of the new macbook
and if you ever need to plug in even so
much as a mouse or a flash card reader
let alone a display or anything bigger
it turns this simple elegant machine
into like an octopus with adapters for
arms and the other thing this laptop is
too thin for is a normal moving trackpad
so there's literally not enough room to
have a trackpad that can mechanically
click so apple has a large glass surface
where the trackpad normally is and then
underneath it they have a vibration
motor kind of like the one you have in
your phone and it's a pressure sensitive
surface so when you press a bit harder
on it
it clicks or at least it feels like it
does it feels exactly like a mechanical
click from a normal macbook trackpad and
it actually fold me into thinking it was
actually moving but it's not if you turn
off the effect it's just like pressing
down on a metal sheet so you don't feel
anything move kind of like a magic trick
so with this pressure sensitivity you
also get something called force touch so
it's sort of like a third click action
you have regular clicks then right
clicks and then force touch so force
touch is sort of like a more info button
you press down hard on like a piece of
text to expand and get a dictionary
definition or you can force touch on an
address to get an apple maps listing etc
so you get the idea you can also use it
to fast forward through a video in
quicktime so the harder you press the
faster you scrub which is a neat little
demo you can press down and it'll click
multiple times even though it's clearly
not moving overall i was pretty
impressed with how well this trackpad
worked and apple's been doing trackpads
really well for years now so you could
say it's a risky move for them to change
it but it's really impressive now the
one thing this laptop was not too thin
for was pixels they packed a high
resolution display into this guy and it
looks really good so good in fact that
this guy thought it was a touchscreen
for some reason they say it's a retina
display and it comes in at 2304 by 1440
pixels on a 12 inch panel it's a bit of
an odd resolution but i can promise you
it looks really sharp really bright very
vivid colors were fantastic viewing
angles are great it's an awesome display
i don't even need to spend more time
with it to be able to tell you that so
all in all this is clearly apple's
sexiest laptop ever no doubt but mostly
because of just how thin and light and
ultra portable it is in fact it reminds
me of that whole
ultrabook category it's rocking an intel
core m dual core processor clearly it is
not a powerful machine at all you don't
expect to edit videos or photos on this
thing don't expect any graphic design
it's really more of a glorified tablet
connected to a keyboard sort of feel and
that's really what the internals are
actually a whole ton of battery and then
the computer parts itself can fit in the
palm of your hand
it's fanless so there are no moving
parts and it's silent and of course with
no upgradability and the starting price
at 12.99
who will like this uh so it's an awesome
note-taking machine you know if the
keyboard holds up students will like it
uh it's supposed to have an eight to ten
hour battery life with the typical web
browsing and like i said very
lightweight tasks that it's designed to
do so it's really just for everyday
people looking to kick back and have a
super thin laptop to do whatever and i
guess that's apple's target demographic
in a nutshell there are plenty of other
things i could complain about like it's
only a 480p webcam on the front like
really not even 720p uh and for 15.99 of
an upgrade price you still get half a
terabyte of storage and eight gigs of
ram and it's still dual core so you know
people are going to talk about that but
people won't be buying this laptop for
the power they'll buy it for how pretty
it looks and then they'll deal with all
the adapters and sacrifices you made to
get there so if you're thinking about it
keep in mind well number one that the
full review and comparisons with other
machines is in the works and number two
this is a first gen product so keep the
second gen in mind because you know
apple already has
thanks for watching this first hands-on
and impressions video and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace